la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons ainsi un dimanche après-midi
pour examiner cette huitième motion de
censure de la législature devant un
hémicycle il faut bien le dire de plus
en plus vite à chaque fois on en vient
presque à croire que les plus enragés
d'entre vous
c'est un terme que j'emprunte à
l'histoire de la Révolution et dont je
sais que certains d'entre vous seront
appréciés le clin d'oeil à leur histoire
donc je reprends je remarque que vos
bancs je remarque que vos bancs sont de
plus en plus vides à chaque fois et que
même les plus enragés semblent avoir
perdu leur mordant et sont désormais aux
abonnés absents partie 239 lors de
l'adoption en première lecture de la
première partie de ce PLF le nombre de
votants s'est progressivement
tasser jusqu'à atteindre 87 pour
l'adoption définitive du pdfss soit à
peine plus de 55% des députés nupestres
est-ce d'ailleurs vraiment pertinent de
parler encore de nupes aujourd'hui on le
voit au fil des motion de censure la
France insoumise fait désormais cavalier
seul au milieu de cet attelage baroque
qui survitenant ma langue au gré des
saillie tantôt completiste tantôt
anti-européenne tanti composant
complaisante avec les violents d'un chef
de fil qui n'a plus que rancœur la
frustration à offrir aux Français une
fois de plus aujourd'hui vous êtes donc
seul à déposer cette motion de censure
et si je peux me permettre ça se voit
pourquoi parce qu'un détail ma
particulièrement marqué dans la
rédaction de cette notion par rapport à
celle déposée avec l'ensemble de vos
soi-disant partenaires le 30 novembre
sur le PLFSS si le fond reste
relativement identique et je respecte
tout à fait les différences que nous
avons à sous-titre sur la forme un
paragraphe a disparu et pas n'importe
lequel celui qui empêche à coup sûr
l'extrême droite de voter le texte
quelle conclusion en tirer après la
semaine que nous venons de passer au
cours de laquelle je le rappelle la
France insoumise assumée pendant de
longues heures et non sans une certaine
fierté de rapporter un texte au cœur de
la niche du rassemblement national je
vous le dis avec d'autant plus de
tranquillité que j'ai personnellement
appelé à voter dès le 13 juin pour vous
lors des duels avec le rassemblement
national
l'idée sur ce point comme sur tant
d'autres grands temps de mettre en
cohérence vos paroles et vos actes il en
va de votre crédibilité en tout cas de
ce qu'il en reste certains s'étonnent du
nombre d'engagements de la
responsabilité du gouvernement depuis
fin octobre leur nom peut être
impressionnant il est vrai sans
explication mais au fond c'est un seul
et même budget que nous examinons et sur
lequel le 49.3 est utilisé plusieurs
fois et nous devrions d'ailleurs
considérer que c'est un seul et même
recours à cette alinéa comme le
sous-entend le texte de la Constitution
je crois d'ailleurs pouvoir dire qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment d'autres options
toutes les oppositions de l'extrême
droite à la gauche extrême
avait annoncé vouloir voté contre ce
budget avant même sa présentation il
faut pourtant donner un budget à la
France et je crains que la procédure de
mise en vigueur du projet de loi de
finance par ordonnance prévue à
l'avant-dernière alinéa de l'article 47
aurait à raison probablement suscité des
critiques plus fortes encore j'ai
entendu monsieur le Président Coquerel
en commission des finances mercredi soir
faire un lien entre droit du Parlement
consentement à l'impôt et démocratie je
vais vous dire à quel point vous avez
raison chers collègues mais vous oubliez
dans votre raisonnement un point aussi
important si ce n'est plus
ce qui qualifie la qualité parlementaire
d'une constitution c'est la
responsabilité du Gouvernement devant la
chambre devant la représentation
nationale loin d'être une atteinte pure
et simple au droit du Parlement
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
Gouvernement sur un texte et l'un des
moyens les plus forts du contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement par nous autres
parlementaires c'est donc la huitième
motion que nous examinons et je ne vais
pas être trop long pour signifier une
huitième fois le soutien des députés
démocrates à votre gouvernement madame
la Première ministre et au budget que
vous nous présentez ce jour plutôt que
de vous faire un long discours sur ce
que contient ce budget et ce que nous
avons d'ores ce que nous avons d'ores et
déjà fait pardon à trois reprises au
cours des dernières semaines et que
seront faire je n'en doute pas mes
collègues orateurs de la majorité je
voudrais mettre en lumière deux points
souvent omis dans la défense de ce texte
et pourtant déterminant le premier point
que je souhaite évoquer l'ambition
écologique que nous souhaitons
porter au travers de ce texte à la fin
d'une semaine où nous avons passé de
nombreuses heures à parfois nous
écharper parfois nous retrouver sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
en France je pense en premier lieu à
l'article 7 qui continue à adapter notre
système fiscal aux exigences de la
transition énergétique avec notamment un
relèvement des droits d'actifs pour le
charbon ou encore la constellation du
dispositif PTZ mobilité que nous avions
introduit dans la loi climat et
résilience lors de la dernière
législature l'article 8 modifie de la
même manière la tire verte notamment
permettant de mieux traiter fiscalement
l'intégration de certaines sources
d'énergie comme les huiles usagées ou
les amidons résiduels dans la propulsion
des véhicules si nous voulons ralentir
et atténuer le changement climatique en
adoptant une vraie stratégie de sobriété
il nous faut retrouver la grande Maxime
de Lavoisier rien ne se perd rien ne se
crée tout se transforme
bien sûr notre ambition écologique n'est
pas contenue
dans ce texte ni même dans le PLF fort
heureusement et je crois que nos débats
de la semaine passée qui se poursuivront
cette prochaine semaine l'illustre bien
ce PLF porte toutefois d'autres avancées
intéressantes en la matière notamment en
seconde partie
comme d'importants crédits pour ma prime
rénov ou encore le fond vert d'un
milliard d'euros pour l'accompagnement
des collectivités dans leur projet à la
transition énergétique comme le montre
le texte sur l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables c'est en s'appuyant sur
nos territoires que nous réussirons dans
les prochaines années à atteindre la
neutralité carbone le fond vert à
destination des collectivités me permet
d'introduire le second sujet sur ce PLF
dont je souhaite vous parler en ce
dimanche après-midi le soutien que
l'État apporte collectivité dans la
situation de fortes tensions financières
que connaissent certaines d'entre elles
ainsi pour la première fois depuis 10
ans la dotation globale de
fonctionnement augmente 95% des
collectivités verront leur DGF croître
l'an prochain et je m'en réjouis
la hausse du prix de l'énergie touche
aussi nos collectivités et ce PLF vise à
venir en soutien de nos élus locaux en
la matière trois dispositifs doivent
être soulignés les petites communes à
l'instar des ménages et des très petites
entreprises continueront d'être couverts
par le bouclier tarifaire sur les prix
de l'électricité les autres
collectivités bénéficieront de
l'amortisseur électricité nous avons
ainsi souhaité protéger projet pardon le
filet de sécurité introduit et voté par
le Parlement cet été avec des critères
pour 2023 plus adaptés à la situation à
venir le filet de sécurité bénéficiera
ainsi aux collectivités territoriales et
leurs groupements qui auront subi en
2023 une perte d'épargne brute
supérieure ou égale à 15%, elle sera
ainsi égale à la moitié de la différence
entre la progression des dépenses
d'énergie et 50% de la hausse des
recettes réelles de fonctionnement
ce filet de sécurité a été introduit cet
été à l'initiative de Madame pires bonne
a été porté en première lecture par les
groupes de la majorité a été modifié
fortement par les sénateurs et enfin
réécrit dans sa version finale par un
amendement de Lise manier qui a fait en
quelque sorte une synthèse de tous les
travaux précédemment évoqués comme quoi
même en faisant recours à la Linéa 3 de
l'article 49 de la Constitution le
Gouvernement peut rester à l'écoute du
Parlement et nous vous en sommes gré
madame la Première ministre je vous
l'avais dit en introduction chers
collègues que je ne serai pas trop long
de peur de faire fuir le peu de députés
nupes et de députés des autres groupes
encore présents j'espère toutefois que
j'ai été suffisamment long pour vous
expliquer les raisons qui conduisent mon
groupe à ne pas voter cette motion de
censure je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]